premier hold up sur le net en grand
bretagne victime une banque qui n'a pas
d'agencé fonctionne uniquement sur
internet
l'établissement a très vite réagi trois
hommes qualifiés de criminels organisés
sont sous les verrous
cette affaire relance bien sûr le débat
sur la sécurité des transactions sur le
web
olivier sainte-marie informatiquement le
risque de hold up en ligne est possible
la cybercriminalité est importante l'an
dernier elle a coûté plus de 9 milliards
de francs aux entreprises françaises
dans cette société
on s'occupe d'inventer des programmes
informatiques pour protéger les réseaux
du piratage
tous les deux mois n'est obligé s'il
voulait de réagir rapidement à des
nouvelles techniques d'attac et je
dirais que c'est pas fini et c'est un
phénomène qui devrait ce même
s'amplifier parce que ya plus de gens
qui ne veut plus en plus de gens qui
sont connectés sur internet il ya de
plus en plus de gens qui ont qui font
appel à ses services en ligne
mais le hold up sur internet n'est pas
toujours évident à déceler
il peut prendre différentes formes il y
a quelques années aux états unis la
citibank a été victime d'un chantage des
akers menacé d'introduire un virus dans
les comptes de l'organisme la citibank
avait alors préféré payer une rançon
plutôt que de prendre un quelconque rice
en france aucun acte de cet ordre n'a
été relevé en tout cas officiellement le
chiffre noir de la criminalité
informatique en france comme dans
d'autres pays d'ailleurs est important
puisqu'on estime uniquement que 10% de
la réalité de la criminalité
informatique arrive à la connaissance
des services de police et de justice et
cela s'explique par des pour des raisons
de stratégie
commercial d'image etc une seule ebank
existe dans notre pays un organisme
financier sans guichet où toutes les
transactions sans fil via internet
elle comptabilise aujourd'hui près de 80
mille clients la fraude c'est une
réalité
c'est une réalité d'autant plus que nous
gagnons de l'argent donc on peut jamais
dire qu'il n'y a pas de fondeur mais
pour l'instant nous sommes sûrs ensuite
si jamais il ya de la prod il faut
s'adapter et c'est ce que nous ont
constamment mais pas de panique en cas
de hold up en ligne le client n'est pas
responsable
les pertes sont toujours à la charge de
la banque